after all these years and so many
sequels it can be hard to remember what
really happened in all the Friday the
13th movies let's take a deep dive into
Crystal Lake and map out the entire
gruesome story what's the worst that can
happen in the original Friday the 13th
audiences first heard the sad sinister
story of young Jason Voorhees
he drowned at Camp Crystal Lake in 1958
after two counselors took their eyes off
the boys to go have some sexy time
those two counselors were murdered and
the camp was subsequently shuttered the
camp reopens two decades later but it
still has a reputation for murder and
mayhem and rightly so meet Annie freshly
hired as a camp counselor she hitchhikes
to Crystal Lake opting to ignore the
warnings of crazy Ralph's a generic
townie who asks if she's going to a camp
blood but maybe crazy Ralph isn't so
crazy after all
annie is chased through the woods by an
unseen assailant and brutally murdered
and she's just one of several counselors
to meet a grisly end it turns out Jason
Voorhees isn't the killer in the first
installment the murderer is his mom
Pamela who doesn't want the camp
reopened because of her son's death 20
years of grief have curdled into madness
and mrs. Voorhees hears her son's voice
urging her to kill fortunately an
intrepid camp counselor named Alice
decapitate spamela Voorhees and that's
the end of this particular bad mama at
the end of the film Alice has a
nightmare in which she's attacked by the
rotting corpse of young Jason Voorhees
it's surely one of the greatest jump
scares of all time
Alice swears it wasn't a dream but
police say they never found a body
strange isn't it Friday the 13th part
two kicks off two months after the
events of the first film we learned that
alice is still haunted by the night she
killed Pamela Voorhees little does she
know that Jason is still alive and he's
been living out in the woods
Jason tracks down Alice and totally
kills her but not before stashing mrs.
Voorhees head in the fridge as you might
already know Jason's trademark hockey
mask doesn't make an appearance until
the third installment of the franchise
instead we get sackcloth Jason and
here's how that plays out this time
Jason is going after a whole bunch of
camp counselors in training the training
center clearly the legend of Jason
Voorhees has grown over the years which
we learned during a bone-chilling
exposition dump courtesy of head
counselor Paul I'm gonna give it to you
straight about Jason his body was never
recovered from the lake after he drowned
Jason does what he does best using a
variety of weapons including a hammer a
spear and a machete he dispassionately
stalks and murders camp counselors until
only Ginny is left she eventually finds
Jason's shrine to his mom with her
decapitated head front and center to
Alou Jason Ginny pretends to be Pamela
Voorhees by putting on her old pullover
and stealing her hairstyle he doesn't
fall for it because who would chase
[Music]
after Ginny conquers Jason he hobbles
back to her cabin to decompress she soon
learns that a cute little dog named
muffin survived the whole ordeal Friday
the 13th part three is distinguished by
two major game changers it's the first
time Jason shows off his iconic hockey
mask and it's the first entry in which
he isn't expressly terrorizing a
campground meet Chris years before she
was attacked by a masked figure in the
woods near her home on Crystal Lake
Chris tries to confront her trauma by
returning to the scene hoping it will
help her to heal she decides to bring a
few friends along for the ride because
why not make it a party
come back here so soon I want to get to
you relax enjoy the weekend some of
Chris's friends antagonize a bunch of
scary bikers who retaliate by trying to
burn down her barn that's when we
learned that a wounded Jason had been
hiding in there he immediately starts
killing everyone in their final
confrontation
Jason reveals his face to Chris and it
turns out he's the one who stalked her
all those years ago
she finally dispatches him with an axe
to the head and here's an interesting
factoid for you the 1982 film was
originally released in 3d like several
other horror sequels from the era
including the awful jaws 3d and the
satanic snoozefest a medieval 3d now we
arrive at Friday the 13th the final
chapter following his apparent death in
Friday the 13th Part three Jason has
taken to the Higgins Haven morgue where
he quickly proves he's not quite dead
he immediately kills a few staffers just
to keep his hand in soon enough Crystal
Lake beckons and Jason much like lassie
makes his way back home Friday the 13th
the final chapter introduces audiences
to Tommy played by Corey Feldman and his
sister Trish played by Kimberly Beck
they're both visiting their Crystal Lake
summer home they soon meet a rowdy group
of high schoolers hanging out in a
neighboring house for the weekend Tommy
is a quirky kid obsessed with Creature
Features and he even makes his own
monster masks as you can see Jason's
killing spree inevitably brings him to
Tommy and Trish's house and the
quick-thinking tommy fights back using
everything he knows about Jason Voorhees
he shaves his head and covers his face
with white powder trying to remind the
masked killer of himself at a young age
[Music]
[Applause]
this gives Trish a chance to use Jason's
machete against him and his mask falls
off to reveal his increasingly monstrous
face in the end Jason is seemingly
killed and Tommy looks into the camera
with an expression that suggests he
might never recover meanwhile the Friday
the 13th franchise bounced back soon
enough in Friday the 13th a new
beginning
we learned that Tommy Jarvis was indeed
psychologically scarred by his encounter
with Jason as you can see the experience
has totally changed him in fact the
character is played by a different actor
John Sheppard five years after the
events of Friday the 13th the final
chapter Tommy still suffers from severe
post-traumatic stress experiencing
flashbacks and extreme anxiety as you
can see he's quite the disturbed young
man Travis is admitted into a rural
treatment facility one that's literally
full of farm animals
the staff at pinehearst halfway house
hopes to help the young man get a better
handle on his past and as you can see
this is a rare sort of treatment
facility that lets patients keep sharps
at the ready
Kayson point on Tommy's first day
patients Vic and Joey get into a deadly
disagreement to be perfectly honest with
you I never really chopped wood before
but certainly looks like fun before you
know it
Vic murders poor Joey with his trusty
axe paramedics rushed to the scene as
far as I know there's no immediate
family suddenly employees and patients
are getting killed by a maniac in a
hockey mask and everyone thinks Jason is
back but something here doesn't add up
for one thing the killer's hockey mask
has blue stripes instead of Jason's
signature red could this be a clue that
the killer isn't who he appears to be
could trouble Tommy be the culprits we
eventually learn that Roy one of the
paramedics that collected poor Joey's
corpse was secretly the boy's father
turns out Roy had a psychotic break
after his son's death and decided to
become a professional copycat killer Roy
was a real loner
not even to the other paramedics
well Tommy Jarvis just couldn't leave
well enough alone at the start of Friday
the 13th part six Jason lives the
troubled young man takes a close friend
to Jason's grave in Crystal Lake notice
that Tommy is once again played by a
different actor tom matthews this time
once they find the grave they dig it up
and shove a metal rod into Jason's
rotting corpse
that's when lightning suddenly strikes
the rod instantly reviving Jason the
undead killer attacks Tommy and kills
his up for anything friend Tommy
narrowly escapes with his life of course
the police don't believe Tommy's story
because of his past mental health issues
the sheriff's daughter Megan is the only
one who believes Tommy and she decides
to help him out
Jason quickly makes it back to the place
where he originally died and plenty of
children are already there for summer
camp
Jason scares the kids but for some
reason he doesn't actually hurt any of
them meanwhile he gleefully kills every
adult and teenager within a five-mile
radius thankfully Tommy eventually wraps
Jason and some chains and drowns him or
does he in Friday the 13th part 7 the
new blood we're introduced to the
talented Tina Shepard she is your
average American Girl with telekinesis
and we learned that she accidentally
killed her father by drowning him in
Crystal Lake
Tina is understandably traumatized by
the death of her father many years later
Tina's sketchy therapist dr. Cruz
pressures her into returning to Crystal
Lake to confront her fears or so he says
what he's really trying to do is
understand the scope of Tina's powers by
using Crystal Lake as a trigger she
feels tremendous grief when she stands
in the spot where her father drowned and
she also senses a dark presence it's
Jason and he finally manages to break
free from his chains needless to say the
killings begin again meanwhile a bunch
of teens are preparing for the world's
wackiest birthday party
[Music]
Tina starts getting cozy with hunky Nick
and Jason basically kills everyone in
the film's finale
Tina has an epic showdown with Jason
with her telekinetic powers on full
display
look she can even move couches with her
mind she unmasks Jason and discovers
that he's really let himself go oh and
then the ghost of Tina's father helps
change a son to the bottom of the lake
since that worked so well the last time
Tina and Nick both survived where's
Jason important note the new blood is
the film that features the notorious
sleeping bag murder and then this
happened
the first half of Friday the 13th part 8
Jason Takes Manhattan takes place on a
cruise ship and we watch proudly as
Kristen Lakes graduating seniors embark
on a class trip to the Big Apple little
do they know that the anchor of another
boat has come into contact with some
ominous underwater wires an electrical
current zaps Jason's chains and
reanimates him again
he eventually climbs aboard the cruise
ship in broad daylight and starts
killing a bunch of recent high school
graduates to escape all the unthinkable
horror a handful of survivors take a
raft to Manhattan sure but they fail to
realize that jason has followed them and
how does he fare in the big city pretty
well actually
yo man it's cool
in the end final girl Renny faces off
with Jason deep within the New York
sewer system and she eventually gets her
hands on some extremely toxic waste
the film ends with Jason getting
hammered by even more toxic gunk which
presumably kills him in the final scene
Rennie enjoys New York with her
boyfriend Shawn and cute little dog Toby
Jason goes to hell the final Friday
isn't the final entry in the series but
it's quite possibly the weirdest the
trouble begins when the FBI intercepts
Jason on his way back to Crystal Lake
killing him for the millionth time
things get especially complicated when a
medical examiner decides to take a bite
out of Jason's still beating heart soon
enough some sort of spirit Jason starts
taking over people's bodies and all hell
breaks loose Jason goes to hell
introduces some new supernatural
elements to the franchise for instance
we learned that only a member of Jason's
bloodline can kill him and only if
they're armed with a special dagger
Jason's half niece Jessica soon rises to
the task and stabs Jason with a magic
blade in the end
Jason's mask is all that remains until
Freddy Krueger's claws emerge from the
ground to drag the mask down to hell
meanwhile the Friday the 13th franchise
remained up here on earth much like the
rest of us Jason axe tries to pretend
Jason goes to hell never happened the
2001 film takes place in deep space and
many years into the future the planet
Earth has been ravaged by overpopulation
war and climate change scientists from
the artlessly named earth 2 are on a
field trip to take samples they soon
discover the cryogenically frozen Jason
inside the Crystal Lake research
facility and they decide it's a great
idea to bring his body onto their ship
Jason soon thaws out jump-starting a
highly convoluted plot that draws
heavily from alien and the Terminator
series he obligatory ly kills almost
every member of the crew at one point
even battling an Android named km 15 she
wounds and almost kills Jason but as
usual he just won't die
Freddy vs. Jason was an epic monster
mashup that combined two competing
franchises the story finds a Nightmare
on Elm streets Freddy Krueger in quite a
pickle
he's lost a great deal of his power
because Springwood residents just aren't
afraid of him like they used to be not
strong enough yet so he hatches the
perfect plan back in hell
Freddy poses as Pamela Voorhees and
awakens Jason Jason is supposed to
remind the people of spring wood that
Freddy is still a force to be reckoned
with go ahead and call it the ultimate
PR nightmare
but things don't go as planned Jason
winds up simply killing his prey
instead of luring them to Freddy the
teenagers at the center of the story
come up with a confusing plan of their
own they want to drag Freddy out of hell
and back into reality so Jason can
definitively kill him the final
confrontation finds Freddy loading up on
one-liners while Jason maintains his
silent singular focus in the end Freddy
gets decapitated by one of the teams but
his severed head later gives the
audience a wink what a coy little minx
the 2009 Friday the 13th reboot tried to
bring the franchise back from the dead
once again inkyung Jason witnesses his
mom get decapitated by a desperate camp
counselor decades later a group of
youngsters had to Crystal Lake to search
for in a legal pot farm
Jason stalks and kills them all except
for young Whitney he kidnaps her because
he thinks she looks a lot like his dear
dead mom six weeks later
Whitney's brother clay is still looking
for his missing sister he goes
door-to-door and eventually finds Jason
who's been busy racking up more victims
clay ultimately frees his sister and
they team up to kill the sick jerk once
and for all
clay dumps Jason's body into the lake
but at the very last minute the
unstoppable maniac jumps up and grabs
Whitney
despite the cliffhanger ending this is
the last we've seen of Jason on the
silver screen for now anyway
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bells so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]